you really need to understand who is
willing to pay for it who's going to
lose money because of it there's a lot
of forces in this field but I find it
fascinating I find fascinating to work
through these complicated workflows and
able to make a huge impact on people's
lives welcome to 20-minute leaders just
sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today it's a journey each one
is different unique inspiring let's get
started 20-minute leaders is a proud
supporter of makeawish Israel and Tech
to peace and is in proud collaboration
with secret cord Ventures Jay Ventures
Riverside FM Fusion VC Birthright Excel
J impact leap Google for startups and
hippo and in media partnership with
[Music]
ctec
y Adam welcome to 20-minute leaders
thank you so much for joining me and
thank you for being here how are you I'm
doing well thank you for having me how
are you very honored to have you as part
of the series um you know this is all
about leadership entrepreneurship and
and um and and looking at new old
problems in New Light you're tackling
one of the most I think fascinating
problems um that we Face very a very
deeply personal problem to many many
people around the world an ex an
extraordinarily interesting problem in
terms of the both the scale and the
human behavior associated with it I
remember you know meeting you and Don
onlyi just about a year and a half or
two years ago and I was fascinated and
and you know taken aback by by the
magnitude and the the humanity behind
the problem here and and how you're
you're tackling it and so I'm really
excited to both dive into the the
problem space and as well as the
solution but also your own Journey as an
athlete as a technologist as a leader as
an entrepreneur so a lot for us to
unpack in 19 short minutes so we're
gonna just jump right into it yel tell
me a little bit about this world of
Laguna Health you know what is this
problem that we're in so Laguna help um
is a conversational care intelligence
what it means is that today we have care
managers at payers and anybody that car
for um patients as they're going through
recovery from hospitalization and other
chronic conditions uh have a care
manager give them a call by the par in
order to reduce cost and make them
healthier today these calls are very
strict with a set of question that the
care manager asks and the patients
answer uh and they're not paying
attention to what is said on the call
there's a lot to be um to be identified
as people are calling and discussing a
lot of insight to be uncovered and then
offering actionable action that the care
manager can take with the patient to
make them better so an example would be
that a patient can out get out of a
hospitalization and goes home with a
with a set of papers in these papers
there's all these things he needs to do
or she needs to do reality is they can
understand some of them they might be
scared of some of them we might
financially not be able to afford
medication doctors transportation and
others uh in a conversation with I have
with the care manager who try to reveal
um those barriers and then have a plan
of and how to take care of them in order
to have the patient recover in uh in the
best manner so in general I feel like
there's a lot like and that's kind of
something that I took with me for the
last uh 15 years uh there's a lot of
that goes into medicine people go
through get the best care the most
complicated surgeries a lot of
advancement they get medication cost
hundreds of thousands of dollars and
then they go home into this EV vacuum
where nothing happens there it still
stayed the same that it did 20 30 years
ago maybe 40 years ago somebody would
come to your house as the doctor used to
come to people's home and there was more
connection Community work with
Physicians and clinician was much
tighter today it's even worse you get
this your home into nothing and a lot of
things breaks there so you got the the
most complicated surgery or transplant
whatever it is and that breaks in the
fact that you can't make it to your
doctor you're not doing your cardiac
Rehabilitation you're not buying
medication that's such a low hanging
food and getting people's to be better
overall so I've been really focused on
that surrounding medicine that really
affects People's Health uh for the past
years but but I'm curious you know this
is such a it sounds like such a
fundamentally critical part of you know
the the the personal experience I mean
they are saying I remember where you
know the where I read that the I was
speaking to somebody in the software in
space for surgeries and for
hospitalization and they and they said a
sentence that I that I really thought
was thought provoking you know this the
day you're going to surgery or you're in
the hospital is one of the most
important days of your life
quite literally right I mean it's that
your your life potentially is at risk
now we're talk what we're talking about
here is effectively um you know the the
most fundamental things that you need to
do for to make sure that you yourself
rehabilitate and get back to health what
what are the main gaps that are forming
here that that make this such a
ubiquitous problem yeah so I I think
that some people have a hard time
understanding why would people not take
medications or not what they're supposed
to like it sounds BL you just had so my
husband is a pediatric oncologist he
does bone miror transing to patients so
they take months to get in place you
have to get the donor you need to get
very expensive medication it's it's a
big thing and they go home and they
don't take the medication and it it it
blows my mind I'm like I know my my
husband works really hard to get these
patients to be in the best possible
State and they go home and don't take
the meds or don't come back for followup
or whatever that is I have all this
criticism he's like why are you
criticizing they don't have the ability
the mother that was supposed to buy the
medication has seven other kids to take
care of so that she has competing
priorities we know that in the US the
number one predictor for readmission is
living alone uh but there's all these
things that you can easily overcome so
you don't move in with a with a person
that leaves alone but You' help them
identify who is in The Circle of Care
please let me know who do you think you
can call when something something when
you need something because you will need
something in the next 30 days once we
identifi like do you know how to request
help are you feeling comfortable
requesting help we start revealing those
really deep relationship we have
somebody that said I have no one like
well who picked you off from the
hospital well my neighbor she's been my
neighbor for 50 years I'm like okay
that's a meaningful relationship let's
let's make sure that you can call her if
you need to get sent back to the
hospital we had a patient that had
sepsis we're able to identify it very
early on and because you already
identified that Circle of C like well
which one of those three people you
identify is going to take you to the
hospital now and by getting them back to
the hospital within a few hours we got
antibiotics and they were good to go if
you would have come to the hospital 72
hours later that means ICU stay that
means kidney damage there's a really bad
the new normal after this kind of event
is not good so and so what is what is
Laguna Health to the patient if you're
thinking about the relationship you're
forming with them and the the value that
it provides on a very fundamental level
H how should patients be thinking about
your product and your company in in the
in the context of their own life and
their journey of getting to health so
they're going has uh two main Solutions
uh two main parts of it uh one is for
the care manager so the patient the the
care manager from the pair from the
health system that is calling the
patient and a patient app if uh if they
choose to download it and if the pair
itself choose to uh give it to the
membrane so there's these two ways to be
working with Laguna under underneath all
of it there's all the the magic all the
engine that is running and calls in real
time and giving Insight so care managers
today is dealing with a lot they have a
lot on their plate they need to uh have
a big panel of patients they care for uh
they have to make a lot of calls they
make measured there's a lot of things on
the plate and they need to also really
pay attention for the conversation so a
patient might say a care manager might
call a patient and say uh the care ask
have you been Have you bought your
medication I bought medication copay are
expensive you know I got them and I went
to get some ice cream and they go in
with a conversation but they said
something really critical they said the
copays were expensive is this a problem
it might or might not be but there's a
clue here that need to be probed we need
to understand if there is a bigger issue
here with payment a patient might say of
course I'm taking medication I don't
want to die okay there might be an
anxiety here we need to tap into this
anxiety and the care manager knows need
to know what to do with this kind of
statement how do you take it to the next
step and what is it that you want to do
about it so we are on on the one hand
the patient might itself might not know
about lagona because Laguna might be a
care manager facing only and the care
manager get uh kind of your mobilizing
the car telling you when you're too
close giving you hints your co-pilot
along the way uh hints and insight into
what actionable Insight what is it you
need to do about it the patient might
have the app and have we have um a chat
called Lisa which is an an an automatic
responses to everything they might have
and it kind of sees the patient
holistically uh from the data we get
from the hospital from the paay and able
to analysis what is the risk what are
the big risk factors for this patient
and able to probe them specifically on
them so being at that intersection
between the caretaker and the patient
obviously that's a very it's a very
interesting place to to be positioned in
terms of data in terms of experience in
terms of product you know we're in the
beginning of 2024 we've been living
through What Now ously call the AI
Revolution um of course we we we
understand that you know the the
infrastructure of deep learning models
in particular llms which I think which
I'm sure are are quite significant here
it's been they've they've been in in
Rapid development over the past several
years um I'm I'm constantly astounded by
by what's happening and and I got to
experience Med palm and some of these
large models from from from my own home
but H how do you as a technologist now
how do you see opportunities unlocking
for lagona and for the space as a result
of the global rise in the capacity of
llms these years yeah could would be a
better timing for us with this AI
Revolution y uh the way the company
started if we look at it is we started
making calls with people after
hospitalization that where we start
that's where we penetrated the market
for these high cost claiming for these
people that need support uh in this
conversation we start touching things
that are not only biological so we'll
take a step back a person is buil out of
there three segments biological
psychological and socioeconomical
there's also a confect layout that kind
of goes along with all these uh most
calls to today in most peers Health
System relationship is the biological
aspect of the patient uh about 15 years
ago they started talking about the
psychological aspect of of the patient
and and recently they started looking at
the social determinance of Health what
is the soci economic status of the
patient how does that affect their
well-being uh in our call we make sure
we touch all of the human we're not
talking only of the biological aspects
we're able to collect a lot of calls
like we have thousands and hours of
calls uh where we where we have
knowledge about what people are dealing
with what they had to overcome and what
the outcome was so we have a a lot of
data to start working on and build our
model on top so we're taking everything
we can from the world development of
generative AI obviously but we train it
on our system our our data itself which
will give us this competitive advantage
in addition to clinical model in
addition to understanding risk
stratification better because if the
number one prediction of readmission is
not biological is not the diagnosis but
it's living alone yeah then how can I
start understanding what is living is
all living alone the same people can be
in a relationship if have a full house
and be very lonely what kind of risk and
how do we identify these lonely people
and how does that affect their recovery
how do we uh we know that if a a bus
stop is more than five blocks away from
a patient's home and they don't have a
car their probability of getting to an
appointment just dropped significantly
all these things to be taken into
account when you start looking at
people's recovery people's taking care
care of themselves the medicine is the
same but the people's situation just my
home and your home are not the same
they're just they're very different we
have very different
challenges yeah and I can imagine that
what's what's really unique here is that
you're you're you're uniquely positioned
as a product company that you know
that's very user facing during this AI
Revolution so while there's a lot of the
the the backbone infrastructure that's
being built you you have you have the
opportunity to now bring this to the
world and and make it accessible to the
users and so I can only imagine that you
know everybody probably agrees that you
know 5 10 years from now the ex the the
the patient experience and the
caretaker's experience or care manager
experience is going to be dramatically
different as a result of these
Technologies and you're in a very unique
position to be that that jumping stone
for them right yes and and we started
with clinical trial so we've been doing
it in the academic route of making sure
that it worked before we buil it uh
before a scale and and S so we did
couple
Mish clinical trials um with noro
hospital system and Mayo clinics so big
uh respectable uh Hospital Systems in
the US we publish articles in the
American College of Cardiology we show
that we can reduce your admission by 35%
and reduce cost 50% with a very low
interventions if you think the other way
to like I can give more medication that
cost thousands dollars harder than
thousand of dollars in the end of the
day you need to make sure that the
patient can come to your appointment I I
really feel like something that is such
a taken for granted are really not
working 100% okay so tell me a little
bit about yourself how how is this space
come together with your own with your
own background and take me all the way
back to you as an athlete you as a
technologist how how are all these
things coming together to a to Laguna
Health yeah so I've been an athlete for
many many years and suffered through
many many injuries uh had been uh three
knee surgeries all on the same knee I'm
trying to be consistent on that uh and
had some pretty rough recoveries on that
I think there's a lot of they talk about
muscle skeletal or Orthopedic surgeries
for athletes specifically there's a lot
of challes that come in on what is my
identity am I still an athlete I kind of
had to I saw a lot of it from different
perspective and um you can go into post
trauma and then you can go to post
growth from these kind of events and a
lot of about how you take it and I can
really feel it in my own uh surgeries
and and and path to it like I was I was
had an Israeli National records I was in
Olympic teams like I did a lot of stuff
and and this is a big impact on how you
see your life is that is that how my
life is going to keep going or is a
really big change on
it big steps to take and there's very
little very little support in people
understanding you as you go through this
route um so as I studied computer
science and maths I was an engineer for
many years I worked at Microsoft I
worked at Amazon a lot of those large
corporation I did security for digital
goods for Amazon so making sure that
nobody steal Kindle books or MP3s or
audibles and my husband worked at chill
Hospital La and was like well I do
something that is potentially uh but
more important I said it nicely is uh so
at some point I left Amazon I joined CH
Hospital La in the Pediatric ICU in the
Pediatric ICU you see a lot of very
complicated patients that have multiple
comorbidities and conditions they're the
sickest of the sick within the hospital
you get moved to the PQ pediatric ICU
until you are stable enough and you go
back to whatever Department you came
from right so it's the the most
difficult scenarios and you see tons of
medicine then super smart people amazing
clinicians all around from the nurses to
the doctors to the pharmac it's all top
of Notch and then you see these patients
recover and then fail to get an MRI on
time because it's not set up this way
and fail to take their medication or or
not able to afford their medication but
where are p for everything in the house
like how is it breaking now it's
something
really I couldn't sleep uh seeing this
like I remember the first time I ran
into US Healthcare and how it's how it's
um done is I walked in the hospital
lived in the dormitories I walked in the
hospital at like 8 in the evening and I
saw four MRI machine sitting empty at
the same time in Israel they do 247 I
went to ashod at like 2 am to get an MRI
so how is it not utilized more I look at
the oecd data an MRI machine in Israel
does 9,000 scans a day day when MRI
machine in the US is 3,000 scans a day
right so machine in the US it's empty at
least 67% of the time we can do so
utilization price variation goes from
$300 for an MRI to $4,000 so there's so
much low hanging food and things to fix
uh so really started from looking at um
access to care from from firsthand like
sitting at the hospital being at the
hospital for many many hours a day and
seeing how the AES where things are
broken and then jumped into US
Healthcare uh without thinking too much
learned that us Healthcare is very very
complicated and there's a lot of forces
from each way and there's difference
between how you build a product and who
you sell it to and what incentives are
pulled and who is paying
home that needs to be really well
understood when you want to create a
product even your product that's really
good for the world and really good for
the patient you really need to
understand who's willing to pay for it
who's going to lose money because of it
there's a lot of forces in this field
but I find it fascinating I I find
fascinating to work through these
complicated workflows and able to make a
huge impact on people's lives so um work
at Children Hospital a for a couple
years build a bedside decision support
tool so something to help clinician at
the bedside and the
PQ
um decided to leave when things are
moving very slowly within medicine
because it was more medical device uh
and we had to go through FDA process uh
and I founded a company called Vim I
think you had one here on the podcast
and did my co-founder and
are War them both are phenomenal and
great company yeah amazing and gur aot I
left after uh six seven years uh to take
a little bit of a break moved back to
Israel with my family uh helped them
live in Israel which is sometimes a
challenging task umed a hyper Local
extics Company uh which looked at uh
Distributing Goods in to homes more
similar to how we do it with packets in
the cloud so how do we do
print by doing it by foot and having
local storages uh along the city very
different very
different I I'm I think uh climatech and
overall uh the ecology is very important
I feel less passionate about it uh
unfortunately I I want to be there I
think it's it's there's a lot of
learning for me to do in order to get
there but it's very important as well
for us and went back to healthcare we're
seeing like my my dad had an open heart
surgery he went home with 17 pages and
he's like what do I do like I don't I
don't
know and we are educated and have access
and even with all these it was very very
difficult and I kept on seeing it over
and over again uh and really wanted to
challenge to take this
challenge incredible no so obviously
entrepreneurial entrepreneurship runs
through your blood and and it sounds
like you've had a both personal and
professional experiences that have led
you to the convictions here you've you
have a phenomenal co-founder Yoni he's a
he's a force to say the
least and i' I cherish the the moments I
got to to spend with him and continue to
spend with him um you know this is just
really exciting you know just I think
that you're really at the I know I was
personally very excited about lagona you
know just when I heard about it a while
back but now you know thinking about the
the transform the technological
infrastructure Transformations coupled
with the coupled with the
acknowledgement I think from I guess
society's side that we want to embrace
these tools and that we we understand
you know human decision making processes
need to be augmented and and enhanced
but then being able to now be at that
product layer and and and combining deep
technology with these aspects I think
that's just Ultra exciting you've
recently announced your your series a
and the company's growing and and so
you're I'm excited to continue you know
being a fan from the side and cheering
you on so thank you so much for the
great impact you're doing and for coming
on here and sharing the story with me
this was really fantastic thank you so
much thank
you